هذه ليست مجرد عمليه قتل بل هي عمليه
تدمير جوهرها تجاهل اي شيء عدا القوه
والسيطره
[موسيقى]
انا كنت اخدم بالشام الشرطه العسكريه
كمصور وببدايه الثوره كان في بين
عشره اليوم بس مع مرور الوقت سعرها العدد
يزيد
وصلنا نصور اكثر من 40 جسر اليوم مخابرات
وبعض وحدات الجيش
كانوا جثث الضحايا للمعتقلين بشاحنات
كبيره كنا نشوف قصص للشيوخ
شباب
حتى اطفال
كل الجثث كان في عليها لزقه فيها رقمين هو
الرقم هو للمعتقل
والثاني رقم الفرق
قيصر
كانوا معي هذا شيء لا نجده الا في النظام
السالمي
[موسيقى]
بعد شهر ونص تقريبا او شهرين من انطلاق
الثوره
تواصل معي
عبر الهاتف هو كان صوته كتير مرتبك اقترحت
وخلينا نسحب هاي البيانات بشكل يومي كنت
انسخ الصور بشكل سري تماما
كل يوم بعد نص الليل بس اتاكد انه ما في
حدا بالمكتب من خلال وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي نشروا تلك الصور لمعرفه ما اذا
كان بامكانهم العثور على معلومات حول
اقارب
الضحك واخيرا وجدوا ان قريبه احد الضحايا
هي مواطنه اسبانيه
تعرف عليه ابن اخي في ارشيف قيصر نعم قلت
له انه اخي لماذا قتلوه عليهم ان يجيبوا
هؤلاء بشر انها ندبه وهذا ما مكن من
التعرف عليه بما لا يدعم مجالا للشك كان
مجرد سائق
ربما كان اسمه يتطابق مع شخص مطلوب كثيرا
ما يلقى القبض على الاشخاص عند نقاط
التفتيش لان فيها قوائم بالاشخاص
المطلوبين لكن دون الصور لكن النظام لم
يكن دقيقا وكان وحشيا لدرجه انه بمجرد
القبض عليك فانك تصبح مذنبا في نظر النظام
تواصلنا مع ارمله عبد بخصوص مغادره البلاد
وما اذا كانوا على علم بقضيه جنائيه ضد
اعضاء في الدوله ومن قوات الامن على وجه
الخصوص اذ نخشى ان يكون هناك رد فعل
انتقامي يمكن ان اقول الاسماء
محمد الحاج علي عبد الفتاح قدسيه
جميل الحسن
وعدي مملوك
يبدو ان مدعين عامين يتبعون امرا سياسيا
مباشرا وبغض النظر عن اي اعتبار يعارضون
هذا النوع من القضايا قضيه الضحايا
السوريين شيء لا تملك اسبانيا الجراه
للنهوض به اود لفت انتباهكم الى قضيه اخي
وابنه اللذين اعتقلتهما سلطات السوريه
اخي مازن كان مستشارا تعليميا ل 25 عاما
في المدرسه الفرنسيه شارل دو غول بدمشق
عام 2013 عند اختفائهما نبهت سلطات
الفرنسيه
حيث يقتلونهما مباشره بعد تقديم الشكوى
فساشعر بالذنب طوال حياته فهو في النهايه
يا اخي طبعا
كنا نخاف من انه نقول اي شيء
لان مصيرنا راح يكون مثل اللي عم يموتوا
بالمعتقلات
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 تمام يقول قعده نقعه
تمام
بعض التبريرات كانت ان كل فرع من هو مضطر
ان يثبت ان المعتقل الفلاني قد مات مسؤول
القسم كانكلف بكتابه تقرير مصور عن كل
المعتقلين
عنده ضباط الامان اثبات الولاه بعض الضباط
ممكن يهرب معتقل بمقابل
لحتى يتم نفي هذه التهمه تماما ولعقوب
تدبير كتير عند النظام كان لابد من
الاسراء على عمليه التوثيق الكامل ترسل كل
شيء بمجرد ان نعطي الضوء الاخضر لبي بي بي
سي ام ان والجزيره
معانا عندنا من عندك من العشر سنين
مره ثمان سنين النسوان بالطابقه الثانيه
[موسيقى]
عرفنا ان شخصا من المخابرات الجويه هو
الذي استقر في هذا المنزل
وعرفنا من الاسم انه هو الذي يتعامل مع
ملف مازن ففهمنا على الفور انه كان عملا
شريرا من خلال اخذ مازن ووضعه في السجن
يمكنهم في نهايه مصادره المنزل انه عمل
مافيا بامتياز
سنتين بتوفيق هذه الملفات
الامم المتحده اغلقت ابواب
افتحوا انتم ابواب العداله في بوتريز
وصلتنا اخبار شفهيه من احد عناصر الامن ان
مازن متريك توفي تحت التعذيب طلبنا حينها
عن طريق العائله من دمشق ان شهادات وفاه
فرديه لكل منهما وحصلنا عليها
[موسيقى]